what's on our radar this week Vector
support and postgresql services to power
AI enabled applications why well
storing and efficiently querying vectors
in Cloud SQL for postgresql and alloy DB
for postgresql is going to empower you
to unlock the power of generative AI in
your applications the details now you
can use your database to store and index
Vector embeddings generated by llms you
can efficiently find similar items using
exact and approximate nearest neighbor
search and leverage relational database
data and features to further enrich and
process that data not to mention the
Enterprise grade serving Stacks ease and
familiarity and the tight integration
with operational data check out the
links for more about